Keep this history in mind as we work through
our exploratory analysis. The first thing you might consider
doing is plotting key variables against each other using
the GG pairs function. This function plots each variable
against each other variable, pairwise. You may want to
sample first, otherwise the function will take a long
time to render the plots. Also, if your data
set has more then about 10 columns, there will
be too many plotting windows. So, subset
on your columns first if that's the case.
The first thing we want to do is make
sure you have these packages installed. We use
GGally for this particular plot. We use scales for a variety of
things. Memisc to summarize the regression. Lattice for few other things.
Mass for various functions. Car to recode variables.
Reshape to reshape and wrangle your data. Plyr
to create interesting summaries and transmissions that you've done.
We'll go ahead and load these packages, and
then set the seed for randomization purposes and sample
10,000 rows from the diamonds data set. What's
happening is that ggpairs is plotting each variable against
the other in a pretty smart way. In
the lower triangle of the plot matrix, it uses
grouped histograms for qualitative, qualitative pairs
and scatter plots for quantitative, quantitative pairs.
In the upper triangle, it plots grouped
histograms for qualitative, qualitative pairs, this time
using the x instead of the y variable as the grouping factor. Box
plots for qualitative, quantitative pairs, and it
provides the correlation for quantitative quantitative pairs.
Remember that our goal is to understand the
price of diamonds. So, let's focus on that.
The price variable is here. So, let's look
at the relationships that correspond to price. What
are some things you notice? There's no right
or wrong answer here, but think deeply about
the plots and the associations you see. Write
a few sentences about what stands out to you.